as a woman
as a black woman it is such an honor
that people are giving me this
opportunity to be
heard and to and to hopefully incite
change
mickey made history at last year's acms
as the first black female artist to take
the stage and perform her own song
and this year the new mom is breaking
barriers again
she's one of four black nominees the
most ever
at one time
[Music]
the 37 year old was up for new female
artist of the year
but got beat out by former idol
contestant gabby barrett
as for new male artist of the year
that award went to jimmy allen who
became the very first black
artist to win in that category
congratulations
ah jimmy bro stop playing
representation is super important it's
kind of hard to tell a young black kid
you can be a country artist
when they don't see anything you know
so it's cool to have that
he got winner john legend nabbed his
first acm nod
for his duet with carrie underwood she
will also be a part of history alongside
gospel great cece winans
[Music]
who's performing at the acms for the
first time
[Music]
brown won video of the year worldwide
beautiful by kane brown
making him the first black solo artist
to take that honor
and he's up for another big award you
know if you do take home the album of
the year award you will be the first
black artist to do so in acm history
i never knew that until today if it
happens then
i don't know i'll probably be speechless
the 27 year old will also be taking the
stage at the award show to perform with
chris young
and you can bet kane's wife caitlin will
be watching with their 17-month old
kingsley
she's on the move right now honey she is
probably keeping you very busy she's a
bruiser
i feel like she's hopefully she's going
to be an athlete but she uh she's at
that mode right now and she loves
seeing people get hurt and i'll just act
like it hurts and she'll just
that's like crazy i love it
[Music]
and when he's not loving life as a girl
dad cain's getting pumped
literally to go on tour this fall dude
you're looking buff these days
everyday workout how are these other
moms beating me
how does it feel knowing that you are
going to be hitting the road again kind
of nervous
i hope i don't forget any lyrics or
anything like that oh blaze
i don't know kane will be hitting 35
cities on his blessed and free tour
and is making history as the first
country artist ever to play all
29 nba arenas that's so cool i mean
because you're a ball player yourself
yeah i love basketball so we're trying
to make it a thing where like i play
at least one person from each team no
way
so hence the reason why you're hitting
the gym too yeah hopefully i can get a
10-day contract or something
[Music]
you